uv excuse at c'est une mission dédiée à
l'étude du climat et aux relations
soleil terre elle devrait permettre de
mesurer les flux au sommet de
l'atmosphère le lancement de ce nano
satellites est prévue en décembre 2020
on travaille avec la société space x et
on utilisera le lanceur falcon nine donc
on va être mis en orbite depuis la base
américaine de vandenberg c'est une base
militaire à peine plus grand qu'un
rubik's cube il contient une dizaine de
cartes électroniques
ce satellite est équipé de plusieurs
petits capteurs miniaturisés donc ici
vous pouvez observer le petit carré noir
le petit carré blanc donc ce sont des
petites détecteurs infrarouges donc ils
sont associés à des nano à des
technologies de pointe comme des
nanotubes de carbone n'a participé petit
détecteur on va pouvoir mesurer tous les
flux au sommet de l'atmosphère le nen
cette élite est entré en phase de test
et les essais fonctionnels sont
terminées désormais on entre en essais
d'environnement donc on doit valider que
notre satellite ne va pas être cassé
durant les vibrations pendant le
lancement évidemment donc on a des
essais de vibrations ensuite on va
devoir faire des essais de température
c'est pour vérifier que notre satellite
va tenir à l'environnement thermique en
orbite
il faut savoir que dans l'espace la
température est de 4 calvin c'est à dire
moins de 169 degrés celsius
objectif réaliser tous les essais à
guyancourt notamment des tests
thermiques qu'ils vont recréer
l'environnement spatial
on va avoir la cuve dans laquelle le
satellite va être plongée qui va
représenter l'espace et ensuite on a
donc cette plaque là qui va représenter
la terre donc elle va être chauffée à la
température qui représente la terre
c'est à dire au moins 20 degrés et
ensuite on a cette flaque ci qui va
représenter le soleil et donc elle va
être chaud fait environ 50 degrés au
total l'ue vs cul ça tu représente un
budget de 2 millions d'euros